[Music]
now come on
it's obvious by now you all know i love
an egg for breakfast or brunch
especially when it has a kick and it's
packed with flavor that's why today i'm
going to show you how to make shashuka
but trust me not any shatshuka this is a
green shiatsuka right please oscar pan
down green
we know it's the north african beautiful
spicy dish but we're going green okay
beautiful fresh kale asparagus
young courgettes pea tendrils chives
fresh peas and then we're gonna put the
eggs in there and do a fast bake without
even going to the oven
right let's have 10 minutes on the clock
please
now
this dish
is a beauty
but the secret behind this is that we're
going green not red
everyone's
done this literally
with those tomatoes
and spice
we're going to do this thing a little
bit differently
okay
take your
courgettes
top and tail them
and let's just get a little bit of sort
of life inside the courgette don't just
slice it
down slice at an angle you'll see the
difference
again open it up
we start off with a little touch
of olive oil okay
because let's go in
and literally bring that heat up
they're going to take the longest to
cook okay so
obviously they go in first again
hold them down
and just slice them lengthways
okay now
why green
is much healthier
i love the healthy side of this and that
nice vibrant green flavor
right gas on
i've got my griddle pan ready for my
bread turn the gas up and let's get some
heat in this pan
now the secret here is to sort of start
building up those layers
i got my
baby courgettes from there
look what i'm gonna do with the shallots
i'm going to chop them i'm just going to
slice them i want to keep them nice and
whole
but check out the colors colors are
beautiful
and this is the kind of dish that you
can literally sort of start off
and finish in the oven
i'm going to do this
in 10 minutes as the longer version that
can literally take 20 minutes and you
start coloring the vegetables and they
go into the oven i'm going to show you
live how we can do this whole thing here
in front of us
so shallots
courgettes get your kale
and just literally
slice through there like that okay and
all we're doing now is just sauteing
the greens
i love the smell of that sauteed kale
it's so delicious
and sometimes we don't eat enough of it
in our household cam has become the new
sort of the new salad every time i put
the layer in there
all i'm doing is just seasoning okay a
touch of heat little touch of salt a
little touch of chili over there
and then from there i've got this
beautiful infused chili oil i'll put a
touch at the bottom now
as we start building up those layers
and then look
oscar pan down please pan down
now
from there
that's looking
pretty decent the asparagus
again don't slice them up
just literally snap them
they don't need to be chopped they're
fresh asparagus they're young asparagus
they cook in like three minutes so just
snap them they don't even need peeling
why would you peel something that thin
peel it you've lost half of it we don't
need to
right
now the base is in there okay
i've got some chives
again i'm gonna do nice large batters of
chives i want the flavor that nice
beautiful
light onion flavor
fresh parsley fresh mint
fresh basil you can see why we're going
green now
give that a little stir
beautiful
really beautiful
all those greens are starting to wilt
down the chili's taken on
the courgettes are roasting so we're
sort of getting rid of that water and
now it all starts to break down
beautiful really beautiful
thank you
now in here
i've got my double cream next to that
i've got my cream cheese
okay
this is going to give that nice
sort of
rich
thickness to the dish
mix that in half cream half cream cheese
but
give that a nice whisk
season it okay a touch of salt a touch
of pepper touch a chili in there and
that's going to incorporate the spice
now before that
in with my fresh peas
okay pigs are in
now that smell is incredible
okay
look at that beautiful
so lovely
we've all seen the shatshuka that is
done with the tomatoes and the spice
and the baked eggs this is a really nice
way of lifting it up
now
look at that
now for the intriguing part
[Music]
touch of that cream in there
mix that
in now look at it
now we're starting to add a completely
new layer on there
and that
is going to reduce down
please oscar pan down pan down look at
that
it's like this beautiful green
vegetable
stew look at that healthy delicious
touch more cream in there
with that cream cheese
in there this sort of lifts everything
turn the gas down a touch
and look
beautiful mix that in first
keep the heat in the pan okay
a little taste
correct the seasoning
touch more salt
that's beautiful
really good indeed now
those vegetables are somewhat half
cooked
so
create three little pockets one two
three
okay get your eggs
flat surface
and crack that egg on there
nicely
second one
crack
number two
now you're probably thinking i'm gonna
cook this without going in the oven
number three
watch
i've got my eggs in there
and put that nice little layer
of cheese
okay
and then what we're gonna do is turn the
gas down
okay
right down
right down get your pad frying pan
just turn that around for my convenience
and literally sit that on there
okay time please
right three minutes to go so eggs are
cooking there now i've turned the gas
right down
yes you can put that in the oven if you
wish okay i'm just gonna show you a way
of actually cooking those eggs and
putting the lid on there literally gets
it done for you without going in the
oven
now the bread
there's something quite nice about
having a sort of nice
toasted
beautifully done
slice of bread
on the side
and this dish is sort of finished with a
bit of yogurt to cool it down
so
we get our bread
a seasoning
rub it all in
and then we go on
to this beautiful little
and again push it down get those marks
working
okay
time please
two minutes kid two minutes here don't
draw it out just to give two minutes
you can add
oscar pan round pan around look pan
around there's the team pan around there
you go there you go
right oscar pan down look at this lid
comes off
look at that eggs already cooked the
whites are cooked but the yolks are
still
literally
a little bit raw in there the gas is
coming off there now i'm happy with that
have you ever seen an egg cook that
quickly so good
now finally how do we finish that
we dust
a light smattering okay
of cheese
i've got my beautiful
infused chili
that's gonna dab around the outside the
smell
of this
is even sending the dog into overdrive
that won't stop barking and then just a
touch
literally
off some fresh yogurt
and just drop it in the middle there
that little tartness
lifts up
time please 90 seconds 90 seconds we've
got to go
go and then bang
from there
your p tenderloins that gives a little
lightness just a touch there don't
overdo that
time
to turn the bread over
and literally oh oh oh oh oh come on man
do you want
that chili
is so tasty
okay
that chili drizzles around the outside
60 seconds to go
and then i'm just gonna literally finish
up there
for watch
please pan down oscar and get my knife
pop that egg yolk in there
that one there and this egg yolk here
pop it
look at that i want that egg running in
there
and then boom
i go
one i go two
i go three
i go four
and there you go along with the rest of
the country going green my shoshuka
green
done
to all of you thank you for watching
ramsey intent if i went too quick i
apologize but slow it down
now don't forget to pick up ramsey and
ten cookbook inspired by this series and
trust me you're gonna come out a much
better chef and if you like this video
don't forget to subscribe to my amazing
youtube channel for more good luck